we tell them nothing they got
nothing you think Jrock talking hell no
dog Jrock is my cousin that man would
never snitch all right just chill out
here hey bring that ice when you get
that chance D all right man you the man
D [__] ass cop what if you rock they
hurt you up in there you mean hurt you
look like he just got back from the
[__] snack shop what you say to them
man
yeah
nothing hold on hold on hold on this is
my man right here all right my brother
this man ain't never snitch on nobody
never whatever now
look we in this together right nobody
said nothing
right right right right nobody going to
say nothing about how big girl shot up
that liquor Stu